I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hi. Jenna, are you in the inner circle? I'm probably not. I think I've spent my whole life outside of the inner circle. Same, which is why we became best friends. This is season seven, episode 23, written by Charlie Grandy and directed
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当事两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。哈喽。嗨。珍娜，你是核心圈子的人吗？我大概不是。我觉得我这一生都在核心圈子之外度过。我也是，所以我们才成了好朋友。这是第七季第二十三集，由查理·格兰迪编剧，导演是
by Matt Stone. Angela, when I read you this summary, I think it's gonna become very clear to you that Ainsley wrote it, starting with the very first word. Okay. Enigmatic new boss D'Angelo, did you see? I would not write enigmatic. That's a five-star vocab word. Enigmatic new boss D'Angelo seems to have an inner circle of favorite male employees, which has caused a divide in The Office. Later, D'Angelo's competitive side lands him in the hospital. Pretty straightforward. Let's jump into fast-pack number one. This episode aired on May 5th, 2011. It was originally titled Sexism. Oh, but Greg gave the note that he thought that the
马特·斯通。安吉拉，当我把这个梗概读给你听时，我想你会非常清楚地看出是安斯利写的，从第一个词就开始了。好的。神秘的新老板迪安杰洛，你看到了吗？我不会写“神秘”。那是个五星级词汇。“神秘的新老板迪安杰洛似乎有一个由最喜欢的男员工组成的内圈，这在办公室里引起了分歧。后来，迪安杰洛好胜的一面把他送进了医院。”挺直截了当的。让我们进入第一部分快讯。这一集于2011年5月5日播出。它最初的名字是《性别歧视》。哦，但格雷格提出意见说他认为
Sexism storyline was kind of a nice plot twist, and if we named it Sexism, then the title would give that twist away, so they changed it to Inner Circle. Randy shared with us that this episode originally came in one minute too long. One minute. And they had to trim it? Well, first Greg and Paul pushed the studio to let them have an extra minute of airtime, but that would mean that the studio would have to sell one minute less ads. So guess what they said? They said, nope. That was a hard pass. They suggested that we cut the credits down, because we've done that before. Yeah. But Greg and Paul felt that it was really important to
性别歧视的剧情线算是一个挺不错的剧情反转，如果我们把它命名为性别歧视，那么剧名就会把这个反转提前剧透，所以他们把它改成了《核心圈》。兰迪跟我们分享说，这一集最初剪出来超长了一分钟。整整一分钟。而他们不得不进行删减？好吧，首先格雷格和保罗敦促制片厂让他们多出一分钟的播出时间，但这意味着制片厂要少卖一分钟的广告。所以你猜他们怎么说？他们说，不行。那是绝对不行的。他们建议我们缩减演职员表，因为我们以前这么干过。是的。但格雷格和保罗觉得这真的非常重要，
establish the new credit sequence with Steve leaving. So eventually, they found a way to edit the episode down to the standard 21 minutes and 35 seconds of running time. Well, if you guys have the DVDs, there's some real nuggets and deleted scenes, and now that makes sense to me, and I'm gonna share some of them in this episode. Very good. Fast-pack number two. This episode was a bottle show. We've talked about those before, and because it was so contained, we were actually able to shoot this episode in only four days, rather than the usual five days. I bet everyone was excited about that. Well, we did not get a day off. Oh.
要通过史蒂夫的离开来确立新的片头序列。所以最终，他们找到了把这一集剪辑到标准的21分35秒片长的办法。好吧，如果你们有DVD的话，里面有一些真正的精华和被删减的片段，现在这对我来说说得通了，我将在这一集中分享其中的一些。很好。第二部分快讯。这一集是一个“密室剧”。我们以前讨论过这些，正因为场景如此局限，我们实际上只用了短短四天就拍完了这一集，而不是通常的五天。我敢打赌每个人都很兴奋。好吧，我们并没有得到一天假期。哦。
We used the extra day to do that extra shooting on Goodbye Michael. Oh. Now, you know these bottle shows. The idea of them is that they're supposed to be very easy, very drama-free episodes. Yeah. No big stunts, no big to-dos, no craziness, no locations, nothing. Well, this was not a drama-free episode. First, we had the running-time drama. Right. That was a bunch of emails back and forth. Then, Randy said there was a standards and practices drama. For what? You're gonna have to wait for it. Oh. I'm racking my brain. What did they get all of tizzy about? I know. There was an ad sales drama. There was a music drama, and we'll get to it.
我们利用多出的一天在《告别迈克尔》里进行了额外的拍摄。哦。现在，你们都知道这种密室剧。它们的理念就是应该是非常轻松、完全没有戏剧冲突的剧集。是的。没有大的特技，没有大动作，没有疯狂的桥段，没有外景，什么都没有。好吧，这不是一集没有戏剧冲突的剧。首先，我们有片长的戏剧冲突。没错。那是来来回回的一堆电子邮件。然后，兰迪说还有尺度与实践部的戏剧冲突。为了什么？你们得拭目以待。哦。我在绞尽脑汁。他们到底为了什么大惊小怪？我知道。有一个广告销售的戏剧冲突。还有一个音乐的戏剧冲突，我们等会儿会讲到。
There was a stunt. Terribly wrong. Yeah. That's the one I thought you were gonna lead with, because you guys, we almost like seriously injured Will Ferrell. Yeah. We'll get to it. Yeah. Yeah. It was crazy. Fastback number three. This was our first episode without Steve. It was our last episode with Will Ferrell. We got a fan question from Katie B and Dallas, Texas, who wanted to know how was it the first day on set without Steve? Katie, it was bizarre. It was super weird. Yeah. When I watched the credit sequence in this episode and he wasn't in it, I was crushed. And it kind of reminds me like that's what it was like to show up and
还有一个特技。出了严重的问题。是的。这就是我以为你要先说的那个，因为大家，我们差点严重伤害了威尔·法瑞尔。是的。我们会讲到的。是的。太疯狂了。第三部分快讯。这是我们没有史蒂夫的第一集。这是我们有威尔·法瑞尔的最后一集。我们收到了来自得克萨斯州达拉斯的凯蒂·伯特的粉丝提问，她想知道没有史蒂夫在片场的头一天是什么样的？凯蒂，太离谱了。超级诡异。是的。当我看到这一集的片头序列里没有他时，我心碎了。这有点让我想起，那种感觉就像是你去上班，
then he wasn't in hair and makeup. He wasn't there to talk to us about his favorite pizza. It was super odd. And we loved Will. Like, thank goodness for Will and the positive energy he brought, but it was just flat out weird going to work without the main person. We had all sort of been working around as a cast, his character. It was really, it was really crazy, Katie. Well, listen, that's all I got. Fastfax were literally fast today. I have a new DVD alert. Oh, like, why do I say alert? Alert. Breaking news. Breaking news. We are now on disc five of season seven. For those of you who are rewatching with the DVD box set, here are a
然后他不在化妆间。他不在那里跟我们聊他最喜欢的披萨。这超级奇怪。我们很喜欢威尔。谢天谢地有威尔以及他带来的积极能量，但没有主要演员去上班，感觉简直怪透了。我们整个剧组之前都是围绕着他的角色在工作的。真的，真的很疯狂，凯蒂。好吧，听着，我就这些了。今天的快讯真的是名副其实的快。我有一个新的DVD警报。哦，等等，我为什么说警报？警报。突发新闻。突发新闻。我们现在在第七季的第五碟。对于那些正通过DVD套装重温的剧迷，这里有
few of the features on this DVD. In addition to the usual deleted scenes, there is a commentary and there is also a great blooper reel and the web episode series, the third floor. Angela, when Randy sent us all his facts for this episode this week, he said he was very sad to put that last DVD in his player because, you know, he leaves us at the end of the season. Yeah. So we had Steve exit during the season and Randy exited at the end of the season. It was an emotional last few episodes. Yeah, it was. All right. Well, should we take a break and then get right to it? Let's do it.
这张DVD的几个特色内容。除了常规的被删减片段，还有一条评论音轨，还有一个很棒的NG花絮集锦以及网络剧集系列《三楼》。安吉拉，当兰迪这周给我们发送这一集的所有资料时，他说他非常难过把最后一张DVD放进他的播放器里，因为你知道的，他在季末离开了。是的。所以我们在这一季中安排了史蒂夫退场，而兰迪在季末退场。这是充满情感的最后几集。是的，确实如此。好吧，我们要不要休息一下，然后直接进入正题？我们开始吧。
This episode opens with a conference room meeting. DeAngelo is laying down the law and anyone who doesn't like how he does things can just walk right out the door. But they're all things people like. Like he wants to end the workday at five. He wants to have ice cream on Thursdays. He tells Darryl, I'm going to give you a full ride. We're going to pay for you to go to business school. Deal with it. At 23 seconds, I don't know if you noticed, but Darryl is back to wearing his shirt and tie. I did notice. I also caught what I think might be an improv. When Darryl says seriously, DeAngelo says, stone cold seriously. I
这一集以一个会议室会议开场。迪安杰洛正在立规矩，任何不喜欢他做事方式的人都可以直接走出大门。但这些都是人们喜欢的事情。比如他想在五点结束工作日。他想在周四吃冰淇淋。他告诉达里尔，我要给你全额资助。我们要出钱让你去商学院。接受现实吧。在23秒处，我不知道你们有没有注意到，达里尔又穿回了衬衫和领带。我注意到了。我还捕捉到了一个我猜可能是即兴发挥的细节。当达里尔说“认真的吗”，迪安杰洛说“冷酷地认真”。我
looked in the script. That line was not there. In the script, DeAngelo just says, no, I'm kidding. Yes, I'm serious. So I wonder if this is a little bit of Will Farrell. I absolutely loved Craig Robinson's performance in this whole episode. If you watch this episode, you have to watch all of his reactions in the background. Every line he delivers. I don't know. This was like an I love Craig Robinson episode for me. He is great. And I love the Darryl storyline of him going to night school. I do have a little bit of a bust on Craig. What's that? At one minute, you can totally see him starting to break. Shoulders are shaking because I
查了剧本。那句台词并不在里面。在剧本里，迪安杰洛只是说，“不，我开玩笑呢。对，我是认真的。”所以我很好奇这是否有点威尔·法瑞尔的风格。我非常喜欢克雷格·罗宾逊在这整集里的表演。如果你看这一集，你必须看他在背景里的所有反应。他说的每一句台词。不知道。对我来说这就像是一集我爱克雷格·罗宾逊的剧。他太棒了。而且我很喜欢达里尔去上夜校的这条剧情线。我对克雷格确实有点小抓包。什么抓包？在一分钟的时候，你完全能看出他开始笑场了。肩膀在抖，因为我
think this part wasn't scripted as well. When DeAngelo is saying, and Toby, you're getting a new chair, whether he likes it or not. Toby says, thanks. And DeAngelo says, don't thank me. Hey, don't thank me guy. That wasn't in the script. And you can see Craig's like shoulders, like shaking. I mean, we should say that Will like what improvised here and there and we would all lose it. Will can read the phone book and be fine. I mean, every line he says is funny. Alright, so now the episode begins. DeAngelo and Darryl are arriving to work and Pam is going to interrupt their chat to tell him about her friend Karla, who might make a great
觉得这段也不是按剧本演的。当迪安杰洛说：“托比，无论他喜欢与否，你都要换一把新椅子。”托比说：“谢谢。”迪安杰洛说：“别谢我。嘿，别谢我，伙计。”那不在剧本里。你可以看到克雷格的肩膀在抖。我的意思是，我们得说威尔在这里和那里确实有一些即兴发挥，而我们都会笑崩溃。威尔就算读电话本也能表现得很好。我的意思是，他说出的每一句台词都很搞笑。好吧，现在这一集开始了。迪安杰洛和达里尔到达公司，潘打断了他们的聊天，跟他说起她的朋友卡拉，她可能会是一个极好的
executive assistant. I remember that the NBC photographer was here this day when we were shooting this and they took pictures of this scene and I charged them. I bet. Well, you know, Pam's runner with the resumes was bigger. There's more of it in deleted scenes. I'm going to share some of it. But one of the things that tickled me, Jenna, is I'm such a nerd for this, for whatever character gets to say the title of a movie or an episode. I just think it's so cool. And Pam gets to say the title of this episode. Really? Yeah. She says to Jim, Oh, is that what he says in your little inner circle meetings? Oh, yes, you're right. I was
行政助理。我记得我们拍这一天的时候，NBC的摄影师就在这里，他们拍了这场戏的照片，我还管他们收钱了。我敢说。好吧，你知道的，潘带着简历满处跑的情节其实更长。被删减片段里有更多内容。我会分享其中的一部分。但有一点让我觉得很好笑，珍娜，我对此真是个书呆子，无论哪个角色有机会说出一部电影或是一集剧的剧名，我都觉得酷毙了。而潘说出了这一集的剧名。真的吗？对。她对吉姆说，“哦，这就是他在你的那些小型核心圈会议上说的吗？”哦，对，你是对的。我当时想：
like, ah, she said the title. I'm a dork for stuff like that. You point it out every time. I know. It's very cute. Okay. We got a fan catch from Aiden W in Portland, Oregon, who said there are three Carlas in the office. There is Karla, the mission trip leader. Karla, Pam's executive assistant friend. And coming up Karla Fern, Andy's agent. What are the writer's obsession with the name Karla? I've personally never met a Karla in my life. Wow. I didn't realize there were three. Yeah, three Carlos. That's such a great catch. Andy and Pam are convinced there's an inner circle. Jim's like, no, there's no inner circle.
“啊，她说了剧名。”我对这种事就是个书呆子。你每次都要指出来。我知道。这很可爱。好的。我们收到了来自俄勒冈州波特兰市的 Aiden W 的粉丝抓包，他说办公室里有三个卡拉。一个是卡拉，宣教之旅的领队。一个是卡拉，潘的行政助理朋友。接下来还有卡拉·费恩，安迪的经纪人。编剧们对“卡拉”这个名字到底有什么执念？我个人生活中从来没遇到过叫卡拉的人。哇。我没意识到有三个。对，三个卡拉。真是个绝妙的抓包。安迪和潘确信存在一个核心圈。吉姆却说，不，根本没有核心圈。
And Kevin's like, he only says that because he's in it. And then Kevin is so proud. He's like, mom, I'm in the inner circle. I loved that Kevin was in the inner circle. It was such a nice twist. Unexpected. Someone who is not in the inner circle or who doesn't want to be in the inner circle is Dwight. And D'Angelo is doing everything he can to get Dwight on his good side. He tries to bring him a coffee from downstairs. Dwight throws it in the trash. Not interested. Not interested. As soon as D'Angelo tries to entice Dwight with like some beers and he said they can listen to automatic for the people on
凯文则说，他这么说只是因为他在圈里。然后凯文骄傲得不行。他说：“妈妈，我在核心圈里。”我好喜欢凯文在核心圈里。这真是一个绝妙的反转。出乎意料。一个不在核心圈里、或者说不想加入核心圈的人是德怀特。而迪安杰洛正在竭尽全力把德怀特拉拢到自己这边。他试着给德怀特带一杯楼下的咖啡。德怀特直接把它扔进了垃圾桶。不感兴趣。不感兴趣。一等迪安杰洛试图用几瓶啤酒来诱惑德怀特，并说他们可以在他的点唱机上听《Automatic for the People》这张专辑时，
his jukebox. Lady, I could not stop laughing because I have a little bit of backstory about the album, Automatic for the People. What? Okay. I don't know this album. Who sings this album? Oh my God, it's R-E-M. You do know this album. You do. I promise you. Okay. Okay. So it came out while I was in college in October, 1992. You guys, I know I'm a dinosaur. But when it came out, I was going through a breakup. And I'm sorry I laughed, but I just like, I know these moments where like, oh, this was your breakup album. Yes. Did you listen to it? Just so much. Oh, there was one song that instantly takes me back to that
天哪，我简直笑得停不下来，因为我对《Automatic for the People》这张专辑有一点背景故事。什么？好吧。我不知道这张专辑。谁唱的这张专辑？哦天哪，是 R-E-M 乐队。你绝对知道这张专辑。你知道的。我向你保证。好吧。好吧。它发行的时候我在上大学，那是1992年10月。你们这些家伙，我知道我是个老古董。但它发行的时候，我正经历一场分手。我很抱歉我笑了，但我就是觉得……我懂这种时刻，比如“哦，这就是你的分手专辑”。对。你听了吗？听了超级多。哦，有一首歌瞬间把我带回那个
time. It starts with this piano. The song is called Night Swimming. I need you to hear a little bit of it. And then I am going to read you an entry from my journal during this breakup. You have made my day. Okay. Okay. You're getting the idea right. I'm in a mood. You're in a mood. You're feeling it. Now I'm almost curled up in a ball. Okay. Now I'm, I'm opening my journal. Okay. Here we go. It's super old. First of all, you guys should know I hadn't been dating this guy very long. So I wasn't like super heartbroken. I was more just really ticked off. Okay. Okay. Okay. So picture me listening to Night
时期。它是从钢琴声开始的。这首歌叫《Night Swimming》（夜游）。我需要你们听一听其中的一小段。然后我要给你们读一段我在这次分手期间的日记。你今天让我太开心了。好啦。好啦。你大概懂那个意思了。我有这种情绪了。你有这种情绪了。你感受到它了。现在我几乎蜷缩成一团了。好了。现在我……我正在翻开我的日记。好吧。我们开始吧。这超级老了。首先，你们应该知道，我和这个家伙其实没交往多久。所以我算不上心碎欲裂。我其实更多的是非常生气。好吧。好吧。好吧。所以想象一下我听着《Night
Swimming. I'm ticked off. Here we go. October 17, 1992. Okay. Okay. I know I said that I wasn't going to talk about him anymore, but he has stooped too far. He is a lying snake, a shell of a man and a liar. He is hanging out with his ex girlfriend. He has done nothing but lie. It is going to take all that I have to be cordial to him. Oh boy. He disgusts me. I need to broaden my horizons. What do I care? This is all so trivial. I have a wonderfully attractive life ahead of me. And I am grateful that Mr. Self-Centered isn't a part of it. Amen. Oh wow. Oh wow. Am I the dorkiest person ever? It's going to take all I have to be cordial to him. Lady, I
Swimming》。我很生气。我们开始吧。1992年10月17日。好吧。好吧。我知道我说过我再也不谈论他了，但他做得太过分了。他是一条撒谎的毒蛇，一个行尸走肉般的男人，是个骗子。他居然和他的前女友混在一起。他除了撒谎什么都没做。我要用尽全身力气才能对人和颜悦色。天哪。他真让我作呕。我需要开阔眼界。我管他呢！这一切都太微不足道了。我的前方有美好而迷人的生活等着我。我很庆幸那个以自我为中心先生不再是其中一部分。阿门。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。我是不是史上最书呆子气的人？“我要用尽全身力气才能对人和颜悦色。”天哪，
need you to write like a young adult novel series. This one is called Mr. Self-Centered. Then you've got another one called Mr. Maybe. Yeah. So we, do you know what I'm saying? It's a series of just the dating foibles of this young woman who is taking her power back. I didn't even tell him off. Like I just, I was cordial. Take that. I'm going to be not friendly to you. Yeah. All you get from me, Mr. is cordial. That's right. And maybe a snarky look. Anyway. You showed him. Well, there was a moment from my journal. I hope you guys enjoyed it. What's the end of this story? Did you ever run into him? Were you cordial? Yeah. I had to run into him all the time and I was cordial and a bit
你需要写一套青年小说系列。这本叫《以自我为中心先生》。然后你还有一本叫《也许先生》。对。所以我们……你知道我的意思吗？这是一系列讲述这个年轻女性在夺回自我掌控权时的约会趣事的书。我甚至都没有狠狠痛骂他一顿。我只是……我对他和颜悦色。接着受着吧。我才不会对你好呢。是的。你从我这里得到的全部，先生，只有和颜悦色。没错。或许还有一个讽刺的眼神。总之。你给他好看啦。好吧，那是来自我日记的一个片段。希望你们会喜欢。这个故事的结局是什么？你后来碰到过他吗？你做到和颜悦色了吗？对。我不得不一直碰到他，而我做到了一直和颜悦色，并且带有一点
dismissive. So don't mess with me because you're going to get someone who's maybe a little bored but polite. Yeah. One other thing happening in this scene. Three minutes, 56 seconds. Aunt Farm still on Dwight's desk. I appreciate the commitment to a prop. I know me too. D'Angelo is going to say, try as he may. Dwight just wants nothing to do with him. You know, after D'Angelo's talking head, Dwight would have had one. There was one in the shooting draft. There was also some candy bag alts for it. I want to read one of them because it really cracked me up because I can hear Rainne saying it as Dwight. You know what I mean? Here it is. D'Angelo is a fine manager, but I don't do my job for the approval of my employer. I do it because
不屑一顾。所以别惹我，因为你会遇到一个可能觉得有点无聊但依然很有礼貌的人。是的。这一场戏里还发生了一件别的事。3分56秒。蚁场还在德怀特的桌子上。我很欣赏对一个道具的执着。我知道，我也是。迪安杰洛要说，任凭他怎么努力。德怀特就是不理他。你知道，在迪安杰洛的单人访谈之后，德怀特本来应该有一个访谈的。拍摄初稿里是有一个的。里面还有一些糖果袋的替代台词。我想读其中一条，因为它真的把我逗笑了，因为我脑海里能听到雷恩用德怀特的声音说出这话。你知道我的意思吗？在这里。迪安杰洛是个不错的经理，但我工作可不是为了取得雇主的认可。我这么做是因为
if I didn't do it, some idiot would be doing it. And this way, that idiot is out of a job. Ha ha, idiot. I appreciate that talking head. I wish that had stayed in. I wonder if that was one of the things in the minute that we had to lose. Could be. D'Angelo is going to call his inner circle into his office. They're going to play mini basketball and discuss two big business strategies. One, go after the biggest client in the state. Or 50,000 tiny clients. 50,000. 50,000. I don't know. There are not 50,000 small businesses in Scranton that need a paper supplier. I know. Insanity. Andy is watching through the window. He's getting super jealous. This was part of a bigger runner, lady. Oh, mm-hmm. There was a deleted runner between Pam and Andy.
如果我不做的话，某个笨蛋就会去做。这样一来，那个笨蛋就得失业了。哈哈，笨蛋。我很欣赏那个单人访谈。我真希望它能保留下来。我很好奇这是否是被我们不得不删掉的那一分钟里的内容之一。很有可能。迪安杰洛把他的核心圈叫进他的办公室。他们要打迷你篮球，并讨论两项重大的商业策略。第一，争取州内最大的客户。或者5万个小客户。5万个。5万个。我不知道。斯克兰顿根本没有5万个需要纸张供应商的小企业。我知道。太疯狂了。安迪在窗外看着。他嫉妒得要命。这其实是一个更大情节的一部分，天哪。哦，嗯。
I remember shooting these. Yeah. So Pam is gathering resumes and Andy turns one in. He hands it to her and Pam looks at it and says, who is Bernard Andrews? Andy says, Samois. And Pam says, you want to be D'Angelo's executive assistant? And Andy says, no, God, no. I can maybe type 15 words a minute, but I need D'Angelo to think of me as more than just the funny guy. And when he reads my resume, he'll be like, wait, this stud did outward bound and national outdoor leadership school. I have to meet him. Then I'll poke my head in and I'll be like, surprise, you already have. And then I'll be his guy. And Pam says, if you really think that will work, I'll put your resume in the pile. Do you really think that will work? And Andy is
潘和安迪之间有一段被删掉的情节。我还记得拍这些戏的情节。对。所以潘在收集简历，而安迪交了一份。他把它递给潘，潘看了一眼说：“伯纳德·安德鲁斯是谁？”安迪说：“是我。”潘说：“你想当迪安杰洛的行政助理？”安迪说：“不，天哪，不。我打字大概一分钟15个词，但我需要迪安杰洛觉得我不仅仅是个搞笑男。当他读到我的简历时，他会想：‘等等，这个猛男参加过户外拓展和国家户外领袖学校。我必须见见他。’然后我会把头探进去说：‘惊喜吧，你已经见过了。’然后我就会成为他的心腹。”潘说：“如果你真的觉得这行得通，我就把你的简历放进那一堆里。你真的觉得那会行得通吗？”安迪
so frustrated. He goes, what other option do I have, Pam? And then he kind of mopes away. I remember doing these scenes with Ed because I did not often get scenes with Ed. I know. He's desperate not to be the funny guy. There's a whole other twist happening in the office, which is Ryan has told D'Angelo that he's the department head and that Kelly works for him. He's like, all right, keep up the good work. And Ryan says, my pleasure, my treasure, which by the way was scripted. I went and looked. Well, Kelly is not excited about this. She does not like, no, this lie. And they have a very funny scene. And in the middle of it, D'Angelo enters and Ryan starts to reprimand her. And she does go along with it. But apparently she's got her angle, which is he
沮丧极了。他说：“我还有别的选择吗，潘？”然后他灰溜溜地走开了。我记得和埃德一起拍这些戏，因为我以前不常和埃德演对手戏。我知道。他极力不想只当一个搞笑男。办公室里还在发生另一个反转，那就是瑞恩告诉迪安杰洛他是部门主管，而凯利归他管。迪安杰洛说：“行，继续保持出色的工作。”瑞恩说：“我的荣幸，我的宝藏。”顺便说一句，这句台词是剧本里写好的。我去查过了。好吧，凯利可对此一点都不兴奋。她不喜欢，不，她不喜欢这个谎言。他们有一场非常搞笑的戏。而在戏的正中间，迪安杰洛进来了，瑞恩开始训斥她。而她也确实顺着演下去了。但显然她有自己的小算盘，那就是
now has to be the perfect boyfriend. Like he has to go with her to have dinner with her mom and like all these other things. Yeah, she's getting something in return. She hopes. Well, now we're going to get to a scene in the break room that is going to be your first drama alert. Oh, breaking news drama. Is this about the Coca-Cola? Yes, it is about the Coca-Cola. In this scene, Dwight is drinking a cola. D'Angelo comes in and he says, you know, my cousin cracked the secret formula for a certain popular cola. I shall not name. But in the original script, D'Angelo's line was this. Hola, cola. You know, my cousin cracked the secret formula for Coke. True story. I've never had to buy a Coke. I just drink my cousins taste exactly like Coke, but better. No bubbles. Lavendary
他现在必须成为完美的男朋友。比如他必须陪她去和她妈妈吃晚饭，还有所有这些其他的事情。是的，她有所回报。她希望如此。好吧，现在我们要讲到休息室里的一场戏，这将是你们的第一个“戏剧冲突警报”。哦，突发新闻戏剧冲突。这是关于可口可乐的吗？是的，就是关于可口可乐的。在这场戏里，德怀特在喝可乐。迪安杰洛进来对他说：“你知道吗，我表弟破解了一种某种广受欢迎的碳酸饮料的秘密配方。我不会说出名字。但在最初的剧本里，迪安杰洛的台词是这样的。‘哦啦，可乐。你知道吗，我表弟破解了可口可乐的秘密配方。真人真事。我从来不用买可乐。我只喝我表弟的，味道跟可口可乐一模一样，但更好喝。没有气泡。带有一丝薰衣草的
aftertaste. Packed with zinc. Well, when we turn that original script in, standards and practices went insane. They said that ad sales had just placed a huge deal for Pepsi products and we could not mention Coke. Well, our production coordinator Meg Shave, we've mentioned her before, she tried to argue that the word Coke was a universally accepted term for soda, you know, kind of like Kleenex or make a Xerox for make a copy. Yeah. Like when the brand name becomes like associated with what people call the thing. Yes. Yeah. We did not win this battle. Oh, Meg. Meg tried, but Randy said that this went all the way up the chain and that we got a tersely worded letter from the studio lawyers that said, do not use Coke. This is one management
余味。富含锌。’好吧，当我们把那个原始剧本交上去时，尺度与实践部简直疯了。他们说广告销售刚刚为百事可乐的产品谈了一笔大买卖，我们绝对不能提到可乐。好吧，我们的制作协调员梅格·谢夫，我们以前提到过她，她试图争论说“可乐”这个词是社会大众对苏打水的通用称呼，你知道的，有点像人们把纸巾叫克林内克斯，或者用施乐来代指复印。是的。就像当品牌名称变得与人们称呼该事物的代名词一样。是的。是的。我们没能赢得这场战斗。哦，梅格。梅格尽力了，但兰迪说这件事一直上报到了最高层，我们收到了来自制片厂律师措辞严厉的信，上面写着：绝对不要使用可乐。这是管理层
feels pretty strongly towards. You know what? It sounds like they were using my strategy of like cordial mix with some snark. Mm-hmm. They were. They were giving it the Angela Kinsey heartbreak college journal writing treatment. Mm-hmm. Rolls off your time. It really does. It's so easy to recall and say. So in the end, Phil Shea had to give Reign like just a generic looking soda can and they had to rewrite the scene. Well, I was curious about this scene because when D'Angelo at the end says, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, and like runs out, I had to know if that was scripted. It was not at the end of the scene. Dwight just says no. D'Angelo says yes. And it just simply says he runs out before Dwight can respond. So once again,
非常坚持的一点。你知道吗？听起来他们当时在用我的策略——和颜悦色中带点讽刺。嗯-hmm。他们确实是。他们把它当成了安吉拉·金斯利的分手大学日记来处理了。嗯-hmm。不费吹灰之力。确实如此。回忆起来并说出来太容易了。所以最后，菲尔·谢伊不得不给雷恩一个外观普通的苏打水罐，他们不得不重写这场戏。好吧，我对这场戏很好奇，因为当迪安杰洛在最后说“对，对，对，对，对，对，对”然后跑出去时，我必须知道那是不是剧本里写的。那不在戏的结尾。德怀特只说不。迪安杰洛说好。上面只是简单地写着他在德怀特反应过来之前跑了出去。所以再一次，
will be in the funny guy. He is made it even funnier than what was on the page. Well, the next thing that would have happened in the episode, you guys, is D'Angelo would have gone to Pam and asked for all the resumes that she's been gathering. There's a very funny scene and deleted scenes. I'm not going to play it, Jenna, because it's one of those that you have to see. Yes. I'm learning. It's a visual. It's a visual. But basically Pam says, D'Angelo, I looked through them all and I put the most qualified people at the top to save you some time. And he takes the stack that she's so carefully put together and he messes it all about like the way you would dump a deck of cards on a desk and just messes them around and says, no, I have a science to this. Thank you. I'm doing
威尔不愧是搞笑男。他把它演得比纸面上写的好笑得多。好吧，接下来在这一集里本来会发生的事，各位，就是迪安杰洛会去找潘，索要她一直收集的所有简历。被删减片段里有一场非常搞笑的戏。我不会放出来的，珍娜，因为那是那种你必须亲眼看到的片段。是的。我在学乖。这是个视觉效果。是个视觉效果。但基本上潘说：“迪安杰洛，我都看过了，我把最合格的人放在最上面，为了帮你省点时间。”而他拿起她精心整理好的那一叠简历，把它们全部弄乱了，就像你把一叠牌倒在桌子上那样，把它们搞得一团糟，然后说：“不，我这有自己的一套科学方法。谢谢。我来
this. And she looks at him like, are you freaking kidding me? And then this would have cut to a Jim and Pam joint talking head. It's great. Pam is so over D'Angelo. She has had it. And also, we learned a little nugget about Michael in Colorado. And I thought we should hear it. You know what? I'm done trying. You can have him. Okay. He felt the same way about Michael, right? Then time passed and what happened? He just named his new puppy after you. Pamela Beaksley. It's a beagle. It's really freaking cute. Oh my gosh. I forgot about that. Michael and Holly have a puppy named Pamela Beaksley. So cute. It makes me so happy to imagine that Michael has gotten a puppy with Holly. I know. It's like
处理这个。”她看着他，眼神仿佛在说：“你他妈在逗我吗？”然后这里本应该剪辑到一个吉姆和潘的联合单人访谈。太棒了。潘对迪安杰洛真的是忍无可忍了。她受够了。而且，我们得知了关于迈克尔在科罗拉多的一小段趣事。我觉得我们应该听听。你知道吗？我不管了。你带走他吧。好吧。他对迈克尔也有同感，对吧？然后时间流逝，发生了什么？他刚用你的名字给他的新小狗命名。帕梅拉·比克斯利。是一只小猎犬。超级无敌可爱。哦天哪。我都忘了这事了。迈克尔和霍莉有一只名叫帕梅拉·比克斯利的小狗。太可爱了。一想到迈克尔和霍莉一起养了一只小狗，我就觉得好幸福。我知道。就像
they're starting their family. That's the first thing you do. You get a pet together. Oh my gosh. Dang you one minute. That should have stayed in. Well, now the inner circle will start reviewing the resumes and Andy's resume was right at the top. Remember his resume from Bernard Andrews? Yes. In the episode, Jim only says part of the sentence, but if they had been able to leave everything in, this is what he would have said. Uh-oh. This former administrative assistant misspelled both administrative and assistant. Tough break Bernard Andrews. Oh. They cast his aside. Oh no. You know, Angelo, when I saw them reviewing these resumes, it took me back to how many resumes I have written for myself, both as an administrative assistant and also as an actor. I went and looked
他们开始组建家庭了。那是你做的第一件事。你们一起养一只宠物。哦天哪。可恶的一分钟。那一幕真该保留下来的。好吧，现在核心圈将开始审阅简历，而安迪的简历就在最上面。还记得他那个以伯纳德·安德鲁斯署名的简历吗？是的。在正片里，吉姆只念了句子的一部分，但如果他们能把所有内容都保留下来，他本会这样说。哦哦。这位前行政助理把“行政”和“助理”这两个词都拼错了。真倒霉，伯纳德·安德鲁斯。哦。他们把他抛弃了。哦不。你知道，安吉拉，当我看到他们审阅这些简历时，这让我想起了我为自己写过多少份简历，既作为行政助理，也作为演员。我去看了
at my first acting resume. Oh, you did? The one that I really had to pad. You know, I had to like, I did this thing where every production I had done in college, I would put that down as a credit, but then rather than saying I did it at college, I said the name of the theater in my college, because then it made it seem like I'd performed in more places. Yeah. All these little tricks. I really padded my special skills. Lady, I was just going to say I'm going to read you my special skills because I was slightly shocked. Please. Here were the special skills that I put on my resume. There's only three. These are the three things that I felt I could do very well. Okay. Okay. Water skiing. What? I was a very good water skier. That's true. That's true. I could
我第一份演员简历。哦，你看了？那份我真的不得不注水（夸大）的简历。你知道的，我不得不做这样一件事：我在大学里做的每一个制作，我都把它当作演艺履历写上去，但比起说我是是在大学里做的，我写的是我大学里那个剧场的名字，因为这样看起来就像我在更多地方表演过。是的。所有这些小技巧。我真的把我的“特殊技能”给注水了。天哪，我正要说我要读一下我的特殊技能，因为我当时稍微有点震惊。请吧。以下是我写在简历上的特殊技能。只有三个。这三件事是我觉得自己能做得很好的。好的。好的。滑水。什么？我是一个很好的滑水者。那是真的。那是真的。我会
slalom ski. You would go to Lake of the Ozarks. Yeah. So I could do it if there was a role. Yeah. What is this role that requires the special skill water skiing? I don't know. Animal handling. Well, I liked animals. I thought I could be good at... What if they... I don't know. What if they handed you a Python? I don't know. I was kind of talking about cats. That's finally bowling. Oh, you are a good bowler. I am. We still have yet to have an Office Ladies Bowling League, which I really want to do someday. Why aren't we doing that? I want it so badly. I want... Do Sam and Cassie bowl? You guys, do you bowl? There's four of us. I want to office ladies bowling jacket. Oh, yeah. We bowl. You do? For sure. You guys,
回转滑雪。你会去奥沙克湖。是的。所以如果有这样的角色，我能胜任。是的。究竟是什么角色需要“滑水”这种特殊技能？我不知道。动物处理。好吧，我觉得我喜欢动物。我觉得我能擅长……万一他们……我不知道。万一他们递给你一条蟒蛇？我不知道。我当时其实是在说猫。最后是保龄球。哦，你是个很好的保龄球手。我是。我们至今还没组建一个“办公室女士保龄球联赛”，我真的很想有一天能办一个。为什么我们不办？我太想办了。我想……萨姆和卡西会打保龄球吗？你们俩，你们打保龄球吗？我们有四个人。我想要一件“办公室女士”保龄球夹克。哦，对。我们打。真的吗？肯定的。你们俩，
why are we not in a bowling league together? Like Tuesday nights and then we compete against other people. Yeah. Like a pitcher of beer and Office Ladies Bowling. I want it to happen. We could definitely bowl against some of the other podcasts. Do you think so? We could take on Conan. I believe that. He's too tall to be a good bowler, right? Yeah. His center of gravity. I don't know. He probably bounces it halfway down the thing. Okay. We got to make this happen. And definitely we need matching jackets. We need bowling bag balls. Wait, wait, wait. We need bowling bag balls. We need bags. We need bowling ball bags. Yeah. Yeah. I don't know what the other thing is, but... I went with it.
为什么我们不一起加入一个保龄球联赛呢？比如周二晚上，然后和其他人比赛。是的。就像一扎啤酒和“办公室女士”保龄球。我想让它成为现实。我们绝对可以跟其他播客比拼一下。你这么觉得吗？我们可以挑战柯南。我相信这一点。他个子太高了，不适合当个出色的保龄球手吧？对。他的重心。我不知道。他大概会把球砸在球道正中间吧。好吧。我们得把这事促成。而且我们绝对需要配套的夹克。我们需要保龄球包。等等，等等，等等。我们需要保龄球包。我们需要包。我们需要保龄球包。是的。是的。我不知道另一个是什么，但我……我顺着你的话说了。
You know what I meant. I did. I think I might have had water skiing too. Well, someone in this pile of resumes listed juggling. Yeah. And they start mocking it, but then DeAngelo says, I am an avid juggler. Yeah. He says, I actually perform a motivational juggling routine. And guess what, guys? He's going to show it to everybody, but he needs a big space. He needs like an 18 hundo square feet. Well, why don't we take a break and when we come back, we're going to discuss this motivational juggling routine. Cue up your evanescence, everybody. We are back. DeAngelo has gone to his car and you guys, unfortunately, his juggling stuff wasn't in there. So he can't do his routine, right? Yeah. That's what you would think, right?
你知道我的意思。我知道。我想我可能也会滑水。好吧，这一叠简历里有人列出了杂耍。是的。他们开始嘲笑，但随后迪安杰洛说：“我是一个狂热的杂耍爱好者。”是的。他说：“我实际上会表演一套励志杂耍节目。”你们猜怎么着，伙计们？他要把它表演给每个人看，但他需要一个大空间。他需要大约1800平方英尺的地方。好吧，为什么我们不休息一下，等我们回来，我们要讨论这个励志杂耍节目。大家准备好你们的伊凡塞斯乐队的音乐。我们回来了。迪安杰洛已经走到他的车前，伙计们，不幸的是，他的杂耍道具不在里面。所以他做不了他的节目了，对吧？是的。你会这么想，对吧？
And he's like, you know what? No worries. I've got a drawer of juggling balls. I totally believe it. I do too. So he tosses DeAngelo a few and DeAngelo does his version of the matrix, like getting it out of the way. And he's like, I'm sorry, but I do not touch another juggler's instruments. Yes. But you know what? He's got the music. Why doesn't he just do the routine without the balls? Yeah. I mean, we're all here. We should do it. We should do it. And so he does, everyone. An elaborate pantomime of juggling. It was incredible. When he says Phyllis, don't move. He's like throwing the balls back and forth at her head. Okay. I want to point out this is one of the scenes. You can watch this
而他说：“你知道吗？没事。我有一个抽屉装满了杂耍球。”我完全相信。我也是。所以他扔给迪安杰洛几个球，迪安杰洛做出了他那个版本的黑客帝国动作，把球躲了过去。他说：“不好意思，但我绝不碰另一个杂耍者的乐器。”是的。但你知道吗？他有音乐啊。他为什么不直接伴着音乐表演节目呢？对。我的意思是，我们都在这儿。我们应该演。我们应该演。于是他演了，所有人。进行了一场精彩的杂耍哑剧。太不可思议了。当他说“菲利斯，别动”时。他就像是在对着她的头把球扔来扔去。好吧。我想指出这是其中的一场戏。你可以看这场戏，看所有那些假装杂耍的动作，然后看它的时候只看克雷格·罗宾逊的脸。好吧。这是我最喜欢的反应。天哪，我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州伊利的 Alyssa D 的粉丝提问。我对迪安杰洛表演杂耍节目的那场戏简直着迷。那是编排好的，还是威尔·法瑞尔即兴发挥的？好吧，Alyssa，这可不是即兴的。完全是按剧本演的。拍摄初稿里是这么写的：
scene and watch all the fake juggling, then watch it and just watch Craig Robinson's face. Okay. It's my favorite reactions. Lady, we got a fan question from Alyssa D in Erie, Pennsylvania. I am obsessed with the scene where DeAngelo does his juggling routine. Was it choreographed or did Will Ferrell improvise this? Well, Alyssa, this was not improvised. It was totally scripted. And here's what it said in the shooting draft. DeAngelo hits play on Jim's computer. Evanescence bring me to life starts playing and DeAngelo starts pretending to juggle to the music. People aren't sure what to do. Kevin Mimes tossing him a ball. Now, in the episode, he actually hits play on the boombox at reception. But that's all it said in the script. But I
迪安杰洛按下吉姆电脑上的播放键。伊凡塞斯乐队的《Bring Me to Life》开始播放，迪安杰洛开始随着音乐假装杂耍。大家不知道该怎么办。凯文假装扔给他一个球。现在，在正片里，他实际上是按了前台的音箱。但剧本里写的就只有这些。但我记得，珍娜，因为我们所有人都得做出反应，他们是和他在排练中把这个编排好的。是的。我们排练过这个。不是排练他杂耍。我记得我们拍的第一个镜头。嗯-hmm。他开始做那种疯狂的杂耍哑剧。是的。但我们确实让他走到不同的位置，也就是他最后要停下来的那些点，好让摄影机知道他会在哪里。对。嗯-hmm。所以我们收到了更多关于这一集的粉丝提问。得克萨斯州圣安东尼奥市的 Angela Jennifer M 说：“伊凡塞斯乐队的《Bring Me to Life》是怎么被选为这段节目的配乐的？这是我十几岁时最喜欢的乐队，当我在这集里听到它时，我内心的哥特之魂开始发出尖叫。我做梦也想不到他们的音乐会出现在一部喜剧节目里。”加利福尼亚州的 Aurora F 说：“在这一集里使用这首歌花了多少钱？”好吧，你猜怎么着？音乐戏剧冲突。
remember Jenna, because we all had to have reactions, that they choreographed this with him. Yes. We rehearsed this. Not him juggling. I remember the first time we did a take. Mm-hmm. He started doing that insane juggle miming. Yeah. But we did have him walk around to all the different spots where he was going to land so that the camera would know where he would be. Right. Mm-hmm. So we got more fan questions about this episode. Angela Jennifer M in San Antonio, Texas said, how was Evanescence's song bring me to life chosen to be the song for this routine? This was my favorite band when I was a teen and my inner goth began squealing when I heard it in this episode. Never in a million years would I
记得吗，詹娜，因为我们所有人都要做出反应，所以他们和他是排练过这一段的。是的。我们排练过这个。不是他抛球。我记得我们第一次拍的时候。嗯哼。他开始做出那种疯狂的假抛动作。是的。但我们确实让他走到他最后要停下的所有不同位置，好让摄影机知道他会在哪里。对的。嗯哼。所以我们收到了更多关于这一集的粉丝提问。得克萨斯州圣安东尼奥的詹妮弗·M说，伊凡塞斯的歌曲《Bring Me to Life》是怎么被选中作为这段舞蹈的配乐的？这曾是我十几岁时最喜欢的乐队，当我在这一集里听到它时，我内心的哥特之魂开始尖叫。我做梦也没想到
have imagined that their music would be featured in a comedy show. Aurora F from California said, how much did it cost to feature the song in this episode? Well, guess what? Music drama. Oh, yeah. I wouldn't say drama. Not so much drama, but it was just like another way that this little bottle show was more complex than it normally would need to be. So the original pitch from Charlie Grandy and his very first writer's draft was that the song that would be played would be Meatloaf's Paradise by the Dashboard Lights. Okay. Randy said they didn't even try to get clearance for that. There's no way we're affording that song. So super pricey. Super pricey. Meatloaf's super pricey. The next thing that they wrote was Sting's Desert Rose. Well, I guess the NBC
哦，对。我不会说是戏剧冲突。算不上多大戏剧冲突，但它只是证明了这场小型密室剧比通常需要的要更复杂一点。所以查理·格兰迪在他的第一份编剧初稿里的最初构想是，播放的音乐将是肉块合唱团（Meat Loaf）的《Paradise by the Dashboard Light》。好吧，兰迪说他们甚至都没试着去获取这首歌的版权许可。我们绝对负担不起这首歌。所以超级昂贵。超级昂贵。肉块合唱团的歌超级贵。他们写的下一个选择是斯汀（Sting）的《Desert Rose》。好吧，我想NBC环球音乐总监，她叫凯瑞，联系了斯汀的经纪团队。斯汀的表态是：没问题，6万美元你们就可以拿去。但我想我们在第七季中已经用了相当多的授权音乐，制片厂的反应是：各位，你们绝对不准再在一首歌上花超过5万美元了。我们设个上限。花销上限。对。我们现在没有零花钱了。没错。他们设了个上限。结束。所以在拍摄初稿中，查理写进去了伊凡塞斯乐队的歌《Bring Me to Life》。你们猜多少钱？5万美元。耶，我们做到了。但他们不确定能不能拿到版权许可。他们拿到了价格，但不知道能不能通过授权。所以他们确实让编剧们准备了一些替代曲目，以防这笔交易告吹。
Universal Music Supervisor, her name is Carrie, she reached out to Sting's management. Sting was like, for sure you can have it for $60,000. But I guess we had used quite a bit of licensed music in season seven and the studio was like, you guys, you are never allowed to spend more than $50,000 per song anymore. We're putting a cap on it. Spending cap. Yeah. We have no allowance now. That's right. They put a cap on it. The end. So for the shooting draft, Charlie put in the Evanescent song, Bring Me to Life. And guess how much it was? $50,000. Yay, we did it. But they weren't sure they could get the clearance. They got the price, but they didn't know if they could clear it. So they did make the writers pitch some alts just in case this deal fell through.
以下是替代曲目。Styx乐队的《Come Sail Away》。《Come Sail Away》。好的。Europe乐队的《Final Countdown》。哦。Big and Rich的《Save a Horse, Ride a Cowboy》。哈。多莉·帕顿（Dolly Parton）的舞曲混音版《Peace Train》。还有汉斯·季默（Hans Zimmer）的《角斗士》主题曲《Now We Are Free》。这真是一个大杂烩般的音乐组合。不是吗？所以我想，如果把所有这些音乐都配到他的杂耍动作里，看看它们效果如何，一定会非常有趣。就像有一个网络迷因。你把它叫迷因吗？网上流传着把布偶秀的歌配到《辣身舞》最后舞蹈上的那种视频。是的。是的，我看到过。所以，是的，我很想听听在他的杂耍底下配上其中一首音乐会是什么样。好吧，你知道有人做了什么吗？有粉丝把他的杂耍动作拿来，在里面加上了CGI特效的杂耍球。哦，太搞笑了。所以你实际上可以看着这个带球的杂耍表演。当他做出贴近菲利斯脸部的动作时简直太惊人了，因为显然那在现实中是绝不可能发生的。好吧，潘要在这个环节里找点乐子，因为在休息室里，我们管这叫什么？在休息室里嘲讽？我知道。在休息室里挖苦。潘有点在模仿迪安杰洛的空气杂耍表演。而你猜谁其实被逗乐了？安吉拉·马丁。天哪，我太喜欢这一段了。我不知道你记不记得拍摄那天。我记得。我们收到了来自得克萨斯州贝尔顿的 Nathan S. 的粉丝提问，这让我一整天都很开心。南森说：“珍娜，你在表演模仿迪安杰洛隐形杂耍史诗级表演时，是不是调动了你过去作为喜剧哑剧演员的经验？”南森说：“自从2021年1月珍娜在《金钱第一部分》那一集中分享了她的喜剧哑剧经验以来，我一直等着问这个。”哦天哪，南森。所以你这么问很有意思，南森，因为当我做我的喜剧杂耍时，我在里面和休息室里的每个人分享了我的喜剧哑剧经验的故事，我开始为每个人表演我的喜剧魔术秀。对我来说这是非常有趣的一天。我还记得我们在这一场戏里笑得停不下来。我想我捕捉到了吉姆笑场的画面。他不得不转过身去。他甚至不能看埃德，他真的很专注于努力不笑并吃着他的胡萝卜，因为当安迪说：“我为《阴道独白》写了我自己的姊妹篇，叫作
Here are the alts. Come Sail Away by Styx. Come Sail Away. Okay. Final Countdown. Oh. By Europe. Yeah. Save a Horse, Ride a Cowboy by Big and Rich. Huh. Peace Train, The Dance Mix by Dolly Parton. And Now We Are Free, The Gladiator Theme Song by Hans Zimmer. That is a real mix of music. Isn't it? So I thought something would be very interesting would be to like take all these songs and put them to his juggling routine and see how they all work out. Like there's this meme. Do you call it a meme going around where they've taken the Muppet Song and they've put it to the Dirty Dancing Final Dance? Yes. Yes, I have seen that. So yeah, I would love to hear one of these songs under his juggling. Well, you know what someone did? A fan took his juggling routine and they like CGI juggling
这里是备选曲目。Styx乐队的《Come Sail Away》。《Come Sail Away》。好的。《Final Countdown》。哦。Europe乐队的。是的。Big and Rich的《Save a Horse, Ride a Cowboy》。哈。《Peace Train》，Dolly Parton的《The Dance Mix》。还有《Now We Are Free》，汉斯·季默的《角斗士》主题曲。这真是一堆混搭音乐。不是吗？所以我觉得有一件事会非常有趣，那就是把所有这些歌曲配到他的抛球表演里，看看效果会怎么样。就像有个梗一样。你管这叫梗吗，现在正流行，人们把布偶乐队的歌配到了《辣身舞》的最后舞蹈里。是的。是的，我看到过。所以，是的，我很想听听他的抛球配上这些歌里的哪一首会是什么样。嗯，你知道有人做了什么吗？有个粉丝把他的抛球表演加上了电脑特效抛球
balls into it. Oh, so funny. So you can actually watch this routine with balls. And it's amazing when he does the thing by Phyllis' face because obviously that could never actually happen. Well, Pam is going to have some fun with this because in the break room, what do we call this? Mocking in the break room? I know. Snark in the break room. Pam is sort of making fun of D'Angelo's air juggling routine. And guess who actually is amused by it? Angela Martin. Lady, I loved doing this so much. I don't know if you remember shooting that day. I do. We got a fan question from Nathan S. in Belton, Texas that made my day. Nathan said, Jenna, did you tap into your past experience as a comedic mime to deliver your epic
球在里面。哦，太搞笑了。所以你实际上可以看着他用球来做这套动作。当他把手凑到菲yllis脸旁边时真是太惊艳了，因为显然那在现实中是绝不可能发生的。嗯，帕姆在这方面要找点乐子了，因为在茶水间里，我们管这叫什么？在茶水间里嘲讽？我知道。在茶水间里挖苦。帕姆有点在取笑迪安杰洛的空气抛球表演。你猜谁其实觉得挺有意思？安吉拉·马丁。天哪，我太喜欢拍这一段了。我不知道你记不记得那天拍戏。我记得。我们收到了得克萨斯州贝尔顿的内森·S发来的粉丝提问，让我高兴了一整天。内森说，詹娜，你是不是调动了你过去作为喜剧哑剧演员的经验来呈现你那史诗般的
performance where you imitate D'Angelo's invisible juggling? Nathan said, I've been waiting to ask this since January 2021 when Jenna shared her comedic mime experience in the Money Part 1 episode. Oh my gosh, Nathan. So it's funny you should ask Nathan because when I did my comedic juggling, when I was in there, I shared the story of my comedic mime experience with everyone in the break room and I started doing my comedic magic show for everyone. It was a really fun day for me. I also remember that we could not stop laughing in this scene. I think I caught John breaking. He has to turn. He can't even look at Ed and he's really focusing on trying not to laugh and eating his carrot because when Andy says, I wrote my own companion piece to the vagina monologues called
《阴茎道歉》”，吉姆一直笑崩。也是在这一场戏里，女同事们真正发声说：“听着，迪安杰洛是个大男子主义者。我们是部门主管。他从来没和我们开过会吗？”潘说：“吉姆，你应该去和他谈谈这件事。”是的。而安迪完全赞同。他说：“你知道吗？如果他不听，他就可以跟他的小弟弟说再见了。咔嚓，咔嚓。我说得对吗，女孩们？”安吉拉，顺便问一句。你会杂耍吗？不会。你不会？不会。我也不会。我的大脑做不到那个。我不会。手眼协调能力？我有手眼协调能力。我打网球。我在篮球场上有很准的外线投篮，顺便告诉你们。如果你们哪天来我家，我们在车道上玩“马”式投篮游戏，我可是有一记很准的投篮。你觉得你还没分享过呢。
the penis apology, John kept losing it. It's also in this scene where the women really speak up and say, listen, D'Angelo is a huge sexist. We're department heads. Has he ever met with us? And Pam's like, Jim, you should talk to him about it. Yeah. And Andy is all on board. He says, you know what? If he doesn't listen, he can kiss his penis. Goodbye. Snip, snip. Am I right girls? Angela, just a side note. Can you juggle? No. You can't? No. I can't either. My brain doesn't do that. I can't. The hand-eye coordination? I have hand-eye coordination. I play tennis. I have a really good outside shot in basketball just so you guys know. If you ever came over to my house and we played horse out in the driveway, I've got a real good shot. You think you haven't shared
关于丁丁道歉的那场戏，约翰一直笑场。也是在这场戏里，女职员们真正发声了，说，听着，迪安杰洛是个大男子主义者。我们是部门主管。他找我们开过会吗？帕姆说，吉姆，你应该跟他谈谈这件事。是的。安迪也完全赞同。他说，你知道吗？如果他不听，他就得跟他的丁丁说拜拜了。咔嚓，咔嚓。我说的对吗，姑娘们？安吉拉，顺便问一下。你会抛球吗？不会。你不会吗？不会。我也不会。我的大脑做不到。我不会。手眼协调能力？我有手眼协调能力。我打网球。我在篮球场上有很准的外线投篮，顺便告诉你们大家。如果你们哪天来我家，我们在车道上玩投篮游戏，我可是有一手准投篮的。你觉得你还没分享过
that on the podcast before, but you have? I'm very proud to share it as many times as I need to. My best shot is a side shot. Most people don't see that coming. Anyway. But no juggling. Can't do the juggling. I have a very sad juggling story. Sad? Yeah. Did you hurt yourself? No. Did a ball fall on your face? No. I, so she said. No. I broke a man's heart with my juggling. Get out. I did. How? When I was getting ready to move to Los Angeles, I had a boyfriend. Okay. He gave me a set of juggling balls. As a parting gift? Yes. He said. What is the metaphor there? He was a good juggler. Okay. And I had always remarked on what a cool thing it was to be able to juggle. And you met him at
之前在播客里说过，不过你真的经历过？我很乐意随时拿出来分享。我最拿手的是侧面投篮。大多数人对此毫无防备。总之。不过没有杂耍。我不会杂耍。我有一个非常悲伤的杂耍故事。悲伤？对。你受伤了吗？没有。球砸到你脸上了吗？没有。我……她这么说的。没有。我用杂耍伤了一个男人的心。少来。真的。怎么回事？我当时正准备搬去洛杉矶，我有一个男朋友。好吧。他送了我一套杂耍球。作为离别礼物？是的。他说。这有什么隐喻吗？他是个出色的杂耍艺人。好吧。我一直觉得会杂耍是一件很酷的事。你是在……
like Renaissance fair? I did not. Were you like the beer wench at the Renaissance fair? Oh my gosh. I think I met him at a bowling alley actually. I'm not even kidding. We ended up being on a bowling league together. Okay. As boyfriend and girlfriend. Okay. He's like, remember me. Don't forget me. Here are some juggling balls. What he said was, you know, I'm not going to see you for a while. Okay. And every time you miss me. Go juggle my balls. You can practice juggling. No. And then the next time I see you, I'll know how much you missed me because I'll see what a good juggler you are. Jenna, he wanted you to be a good ball handler. Well, here's what happened. He, he came into town like months after we'd said goodbye.
比如文艺复兴展上认识他的？才不是。你当时是文艺复兴展上卖啤酒的村姑吗？哦天哪。我想我其实是在保龄球馆认识他的。我没开玩笑。我们最后一起加入了一个保龄球队。好吧。以男女朋友的身份。好吧。他就像是在说，记住我。别忘了我。这些是杂耍球。他的意思是，你知道的，我们有一段时间见不到面了。好吧。每当你想我的时候。就去玩我的杂耍球。你可以练习杂耍。才不。然后下次我见到你时，我就会知道你有多想我，因为我会看到你杂耍玩得有多好。珍娜，他是想让你好好掌控球。好吧，事情是这样的。他……他在我们告别几个月后来到我所在的城市。
And I had not learned to juggle at all. Because you hadn't thought of him. And then we broke up because you shortly juggle his balls. No, because it was, no, it was like, you know, we didn't, we didn't break up right at that trip. But it was, you know, it was the beginning of the end. Right. You know, it was going to become clear that we were going in two different directions and it wasn't the direction where we both juggle. Yeah. He was going to be a juggler and I was going to be an actor and not juggle. I feel like there's a world where you two could have made it. You'd be like a traveling show. You would come out and you would do your clown work. He's a doctor now. Oh. So, well, that went a different way. Listen, I find juggling
而我根本没有学杂耍。因为你根本没想起他。然后我们分手了，因为你很快就玩了他的球？不，因为……不，就像是，你知道的，我们并没有在那次旅行时立刻分手。但那是，你知道的，那是结束的开始。没错。你知道的，这逐渐变得明朗，我们正朝着两个不同的方向前进，而且并不是那种我们俩都会杂耍的方向。是的。他要做一个杂耍艺人，而我要当个演员，不搞杂耍。我觉得你们两个本来是有可能在一起的。你们可以弄个巡回演出。你们出场，然后表演你们的小丑绝活。他现在是个医生。哦。好吧，事情走向了不同的方向。听着，我觉得杂耍很酷。
cool. I think it's neat. I do. So, you know, I was being real with him when I said I thought it was cool that he could juggle it. And I kind of still do wish I could juggle. But it clearly was not meant to be. Was it meant to be, lady? No. Okay. Well, where are we? We are at Jim asking for a moment of DeAngelo's time. And he has plenty of it because you know what, this job's a joke. I loved it. I loved it too. I want to give a shout out to John Krasinski because the way he goes about bringing up the women are unhappy and then just trying to backpedal and then all of it, he is so good in this scene. But then Jim kind of throws Pam under the bus. Like, what Pam and these women needed from Jim is for Jim to be an upstander. They needed him to go in the
我觉得这很赞。我是认真的。所以，你知道的，当我告诉他我觉得他会杂耍很酷时，我是真心的。而且我到现在其实还是希望自己会杂耍。但这显然是命中注定无缘。这命中注定吗，女士？没有。好吧。那我们讲到哪了？我们讲到吉姆请求德安吉洛给她一点时间。他有很多时间，因为你知道吗，这工作简直是个笑话。我超爱这段。我也超爱。我要向约翰·卡拉辛斯基致敬，因为他提起女人们很不高兴的方式，然后试图打圆场，接着这一切，他在这一幕里表现得太棒了。但接着吉姆有点把帕姆给出卖了。就像，帕姆和这些女人们需要吉姆做的是，希望吉姆能挺身而出。她们需要他走进……
office and say, I've noticed that you do this thing. Let me point out. But he doesn't do that. What he says is, so Angela, that's how he starts it off. I know. That's what I mean. Kevin brings up Pam and then says she can be kind of a bitch. I know. And Jim completely is like, blah, blah, blah, and then backs out. Because he did it wrong. You're supposed to use your status and privilege and own what you're saying. You're not supposed to lay it off on the people who are experiencing the sexism, right? You're like, I've noticed, D'Angelo, that there are no women in this room. I've noticed that Angela is a department head and you don't meet with her. And I think that that is somewhat of an issue. So Jim tries, he tries, but you know, just have to say that.
办公室说，我注意到你在做这件事。让我指出来。但他没有这么做。他说的是，安吉拉，他是这样开的头。我知道。这就是我的意思。凯文提到了帕姆，然后说她有时有点像个碧池。我知道。而吉姆完全就是一副，巴拉巴拉巴拉，然后退缩了。因为他做错了。你应该利用你的地位和特权，为你所说的话负责。你不应该把责任推卸给那些正在经历性别歧视的人，对吧？你应该说，我注意到，德安吉洛，这个房间里没有女人。我注意到安吉拉是个部门主管，而你却不和她开会。我觉得这在某种程度上是个问题。所以吉姆试过了，他试过了，不过你知道，我不得不说这个。
I guess, I guess I had to say that. I have a lot of things to say today. And by the way, I'm not done. I've got something to say about Phyllis in a minute. Oh, okay. Well, D'Angelo is now going to confront the bullpen. He's going to say, hey, I'm not a sexist, despite the rumor going around. I do have a solitaire catch. 12 minutes, 14 seconds. I saw it. Kate Flannery is moving some cards around there in the background. D'Angelo is going to ask everyone to raise their hand if they have a vagina or if they love someone who has a vagina. Both of his hands go up. The scene was actually a much bigger scene. And Jenna, I thought we should hear it. Angela and Phyllis speak up and then they also ask Toby
我想，我想我不得不说这个。我今天有很多话要说。顺便说一句，我还没说完。过一会儿我还有话要说关于菲利斯的。哦，好吧。好了，德安吉洛现在要去找办公区的人对质了。他要说，嘿，我不是个大男子主义者，尽管有流言蜚语。我会玩单人纸牌。12分钟14秒。我看到了。凯特·弗兰内里在背景里挪动着纸牌。德安吉洛要让每个人都举起手来，只要他们有阴道，或者他们爱一个有阴道的人。他的两只手都举了起来。这一幕其实原本是一场更大的戏。而珍娜，我觉得我们应该听听看。安吉拉和菲利斯发声了，然后她们还要求托比发表意见。
to weigh in. Apparently, there's a rumor running around here that I'm a sexist. D'Angelo, it's simply a question of respecting the work. Kevin is invited to meetings that I'm not invited to. And I am a more productive accountant. You can literally look at the numbers. Whoa, Angela. No, no, no. It depends what makes the math did, D'Angelo. I'm not a feminist, but I think that the men in this office are being given chances that the women aren't. Right, Toby? I mean, isn't there some policy on this? Hazy. I had a difficult relationship with my last boss. Not eager to create another hostile situation. Whoa. Yeah. Also, the way Paul delivers that talking head is Toby. He put so many spaces between the words that I kind of felt like Michael Scott.
显然，这里流传着一个谣言，说我是个大男子主义者。德安吉洛，这纯粹是对工作的不尊重。凯文能去开会，而我却不能去。而且我是个更有成效的会计。你们完全可以看数据。哇，安吉拉。不，不，不。这取决于数学是怎么算的，德安吉洛。我不是女权主义者，但我认为这个办公室里的男人们得到了女人们没有的机会。对吧，托比？我的意思是，难道没有关于这方面的政策吗？含糊其辞。我和上一任老板的关系很艰难。我可不想再制造另一种充满敌意的局面。哇。是的。还有，保罗说那段独白的方式，那是托比。他在字与字之间留了那么多空白，以至于我有点觉得像迈克尔·斯科特。
I was like, say it. Well, we got a fan. I don't know what you would call it. I'm calling it a fan soapbox from Anna W. in England. Oh, let's hear it. Anna said, I've held my tongue about Phyllis long enough. Phyllis, in this episode, pisses me off. Oh. Phyllis says, quote, I'm not a feminist, but I think the men in this office are being given chances that women aren't. Anna says, Phyllis, that is feminism. Equality and opportunity, equality and pay, and rights is being a feminist. You are a feminist if that's what you think, Phyllis. Thank you, Anna. Yeah. Because I'm going to say, for some reason, I feel like feminist has become like this dirty word somehow, right? Like somehow like being a feminist. It's become charged. Charged is such
我就像是，说出来啊。好吧，我们有一个粉丝。我不知道你们该怎么称呼它。我称之为来自英国安娜·W的粉丝呐喊。哦，我们听听看。安娜说，我忍耐菲利斯够久了。菲利斯，在本集中，真把我气到了。哦。菲利斯说，引述，“我不是女权主义者，但我觉得这个办公室里的男人们得到了女人没有的机会。”安娜说，菲利斯，这就是女权主义。机会平等、薪酬平等和权利平等，这就是女权主义。如果你这么想，你就是个女权主义者，菲利斯。谢谢你，安娜。是的。因为我要说的是，不知为什么，我觉得女权主义不知怎么成了这样一个贬义词，对吧？就像不知为什么当个女权主义者。变得很有争议性。
a good way to put it, Angela. And it shouldn't be charged if you just want equal opportunity, pay, and rights. Yeah. That's it. The end. Fair. Not much more complicated than that. Can we just get fair? There you go. Thank you, Anna. I liked that. Anna, you made her day. You did. At the end of the scene, D'Angelo's new executive assistant is going to arrive. I wanted to describe this character per the shooting draft. Okay. Aaron enters with a tall, gorgeous young woman, Jordan Garfield. D'Angelo shakes her hand. Jordan seems weirded out by the attention. Hmm. Well, new character alert. Jordan was played by Cody Horn. She has a three-episode arc on the show, and you might recognize her from the TV
有争议性这个词形容得太好了，安吉拉。如果你只是想要机会平等、薪酬和权利，它本不该充满争议的。是的。就是这样。结束。很公正。没那么复杂。我们能只求公正吗？好了。谢谢你，安娜。我喜欢这个。安娜，你让她这一天都过得很开心。确实如此。在这一幕的结尾，德安吉洛的新执行助理要来了。我想根据拍摄剧本描述一下这个角色。好的。艾伦带着一个高挑、美艳的年轻女子约旦·加菲尔德走了进来。德安吉洛和她握手。约旦似乎对这种关注感到很不自在。嗯。好吧，新角色警报。约旦由科迪·霍恩饰演。她在剧中有一个三集的客串故事线，你可能从电视剧《救援法庭》或电影《魔力麦克》中认出她。
series Rescue Me or the movie Magic Mike. When she enters, Pam is suspicious and immediately begins asking her about her previous work experience. We find out she worked at Anthropology, and we learn that that's Kelly's dream job. I love it when she's like, you quit that job to come here. And my thought was, Kelly, go apply. They'll hire you. But she's like, how'd you get that job? I know. We do learn that this is Jordan's first office job ever. Yes. And then the inner circle is going to gather, and Jim is no longer invited. He did not get a text. Dwight got a text, but he's not interested. Guess who did get a text? Andy. And boy, has he flipped. I know. He's so excited to run in there. Jim tries to go in, sort of enters, and he gets fully kicked
她一进来，帕姆就起了疑心，立刻开始盘问她以前的工作经验。我们发现她曾在人类学店（Anthropology）工作，而我们了解到那是凯莉的梦想工作。我太喜欢她那种“你居然辞掉那工作来这里”的反应了。我的想法是，凯莉，去申请啊。他们会录用你的。但她却说，你是怎么得到那份工作的？我知道。我们确实了解到这是约旦的有生以来第一份办公室工作。是的。然后核心圈子要聚集了，而吉姆不再被邀请了。他没有收到短信。德怀特收到了短信，但他不感兴趣。猜猜谁收到短信了？安迪。天哪，他乐疯了。我知道。他兴奋得跑了进去。吉姆试图进去，算是走了进去，然后他被彻底踢了出来。
out. Yeah. Awkward. Up next for Jim, Andy's going to be running a meeting, and it's going to cut to Jim. And he says, so I guess this is my life. Until I win the lottery, our Pam finally writes her young adult book series. This is my favorite moment in the whole episode. The horse flyer? Oh my gosh. Lady, I really want you to read it. Because the excitement Pam has, it's so perfect. It was so cute. I printed out the words. You have to read it. I will read it. Ready? Mm-hmm. So one afternoon while walking home from school, quirky 10th grader Becky Walters finds a wounded pegasus in the woods and she becomes the horse flyer. It's so cute. I loved it. Well, Randy said they had to clear that title, the horse flyer. And they even had to hire a research company
是的。真尴尬。吉姆的下一站，安迪要主持一个会议，然后镜头切到了吉姆。他说，所以我想这就是我的人生了。直到我中了彩票，或者我们的帕姆终于写成了她的青少年图书系列。这是整集中我最喜欢的时刻。那个骑马女孩？哦天哪。女士，我真的很想让你读读。因为帕姆表现出的兴奋，简直太完美了。太可爱了。我把文字打印出来了。你必须读一读。我会读的。准备好了吗？嗯哼。话说一天下午放学回家的路上，古怪的十年级学生贝基·沃特斯在树林里发现了一只受伤的天马，她成了骑马女孩。太可爱了。我超喜欢。好吧，兰迪说他们必须通过那个书名“骑马女孩”的版权审核。
to look into the legal ramifications of using this name in the show. I guess on the off chance that somewhere out in the world there was a book called the horse flyer? Correct. Here's what they responded with from their research. The horse flyer. We find no listings for a publication with this exact title with the U.S. Library of Congress or the U.S. Copyright Office and a general web search found no listings for a prominent publication with this exact title. We were given clearance to proceed. Okay. But like it fascinates me that as a writer, I wouldn't even think of that. I would just turn it in. That's a funny title. The horse flyer. Yeah. But then someone illegal, someone has to clear that. Right. And maybe it wouldn't have
他们甚至不得不雇佣一家研究公司来调查在节目中使用这个名字的法律后果。我想是为了防范世界上某个地方恰好有一本叫《骑马女孩》的书这种万一的情况？没错。这是他们调查得出的回复。骑马女孩。我们在美国国会图书馆或美国版权局没有找到确切书名的出版物记录，一般网络搜索也没有找到任何关于这个确切书名的知名出版物的记录。我们获准继续进行。好吧。但这让我觉得着迷的是，作为一个作家，我甚至不会想到这一点。我只会直接交稿。这是一个有趣的标题。骑马女孩。是的。但随后某个法律部门的人必须批准它。没错。也许它不会获批，他们就得写别的。但我发现这太迷人了。
cleared and they would have had to write different ones. But I find that fascinating. Yeah. They would have had a probably a list of alts like the pony flyer. Yeah. That one. I don't, I mean, maybe they would. Well, after these talking heads, there would have been a scene between Jim and D'Angelo because Jim decides to try and go back in and talk to him. And we learn what team D'Angelo plays for. I think you should hear it. Jim, are you going to understand me if I use a sports metaphor? I think I probably. You're a team. I need team players. And I just don't know if you're on my team. I am definitely on your team. Team Dunder Mifflin. Here we go.
是的。他们可能有一份备选名单，比如《小马飞人》。是的。那个。我不，我是说，也许他们会。好吧，在这些独白之后，本该有一场吉姆和德安吉洛之间的戏，因为吉姆决定试着回去和他谈谈。然后我们知道了德安吉洛效力的是哪支球队。我觉得你应该听听这个。吉姆，如果我用体育隐喻，你能理解我吗？我想我大概能。你们是一个团队。我需要团队球员。我只是不知道你是否在我的团队里。我绝对在你的团队里。邓德米夫林队。我们开始吧。
Team is called the crazy snakes. Oh, okay. Or the Matadors. Or the Lancers. Lancers. Sounds a little high school, right? Yeah. But it's also my favorite. Great. Let's see if we can't work you back into the lineup. That would be awesome. Jordan, please show Jim out. I got it right here. Jordan, please show Jim out. Oh my gosh. It was so funny. Also, they did that classic reveal that they would do when they were in Michael's office where it's D'Angelo and Jim talking. And then at the very end, you see that Jordan has been there the whole time. What is the character of Jordan thinking on her first day? She has no responsibilities. You know, Jenna, she actually has a deleted talking head where she says something to the effect of,
这支队伍叫疯狂蛇队。哦，好吧。或者斗牛士队。或者枪骑兵队。枪骑兵。听起来有点像高中的，对吧？对。但这也是我最喜欢的。太棒了。让我们看看能不能把你重新安排进首发阵容。那太棒了。约旦，请送吉姆出去。我这就来。约旦，请送吉姆出去。哦天哪。太搞笑了。还有，他们还上演了迈克尔办公室里那种经典的揭秘桥段，就是德安吉洛和吉姆在谈话。然后到最后，你发现约旦其实一直都在那儿。约旦第一天上班心里在想什么呢？她没有任何责任。你知道的，珍娜，她其实有一段被删掉的独白，里面她大概说的是……
yeah, you know, so far I don't like working here. That's amazing. Now, Ryan is reprimanding Kelly in front of D'Angelo. She's playing along with it at first, but she can't take it anymore. And she tells D'Angelo the truth. And D'Angelo doesn't really care. He's finding this whole explanation a little murky. He calls her hysterical. And she starts to laugh. Do you see it? Mindy like found that very funny. And then he just says, you know what? Ryan's your supervisor. Done. That's it now. I know. Now Ryan got this job. I want everyone to know I haven't brought it up yet, but Miles McNutt gave this episode a C minus. Oh, Miles did not like it. This is one of his, like, lowest ratings so far. But he did say on a positive note, he said, quote,
是的，你知道的，到目前为止我其实不太喜欢在这里工作。太绝了。现在，瑞恩正在德安吉洛面前训斥凯莉。她一开始还在配合演戏，但她实在受不了了。她把真相告诉了德安吉洛。而德安吉洛其实根本不在乎。他觉得整个解释有点含糊不清。他叫她歇斯底里。然后她开始笑。看到了吗？明迪觉得这非常搞笑。然后他只是说，你知道吗？瑞恩是你的主管。搞定。就这样了。我知道。现在瑞恩得到了这份工作。我想让大家知道我还没提过这事，但迈尔斯·麦克纳特给这一集打了C减。哦，迈尔斯不喜欢。这是他至今给出的最低评分之一。但他确实说积极的一点是，他说，引述……
I liked that we saw more of Ryan and Kelly than we usually get to see and that Kelly got to take a more authoritative role for a change. Kelly's a character whose level of intelligence is always somewhat variable, especially when it comes to Ryan. But to see her shift away from her swooning over Ryan as he fakes being her supervisor was quite satisfying. So he did like this part. Okay. Well, I always love to hear what Miles McNutt was thinking. The inner circle is starting to get really loud and people are trying to work. So Pam is going to ask them to quiet it down. You know what? She's fuming, but I would say she's also being cordial, right? Yes. She's holding it together. We had a fan question from Sarah W. in Kingwood, Texas, and Ryan R. in Woodland,
我喜欢我们比平时看到了更多的瑞恩和凯莉，而且凯莉破天荒地扮演了一个更有权威的角色。凯莉是一个智商水平总是有些变幻莫测的角色，尤其是当涉及瑞恩的时候。但看到她不再对假装是她主管的瑞恩神魂颠倒，而是发生了转变，这让人感到相当满足。所以他确实喜欢这部分。好吧。嗯，我总是很喜欢听听迈尔斯·麦克纳特是怎么想的。核心圈子开始变得非常吵闹，而人们还要工作。所以帕姆打算让他们安静点。你知道吗？她在生闷气，但我得说她也很客气，对吧？是的。她克制住了自己。我们有一个来自得克萨斯州金伍德的萨拉·W和加利福尼亚州伍德兰的瑞恩·R的粉丝提问，
California, who both asked, when Pam knocks on the door to the office to ask the guys to quiet down, there is a clear shot of the window next to the manager's office door and the window is slanted. Is this to avoid seeing the holes in the ceiling or to avoid seeing glare from the lights? What a great catch. Yes, it is. This is a total glare thing. So here was the thing we talked before about how our set had immovable walls. Yeah. Usually when you're working on a set, you can like fly out a wall. Like normally you'd be able to remove the whole wall to the conference room to get a better shot, but they wanted our camera operators to have to deal with the confines of the real space. But what they did do is they made all the windows so they could slant up or
两人都问，当帕姆敲办公室的门让小伙子们安静点时，经理办公室门旁的窗户有一个清晰的镜头，而且窗户是倾斜的。这是为了避免看到天花板上的洞，还是为了避免看到灯光的眩光？多棒的发现啊。是的，完全正确。这绝对是为了防眩光。所以之前我们讨论过我们的布景有着无法移动的墙壁。是的。通常当你在布景里工作时，你可以把一堵墙移开。通常你可以把会议室整面墙都拆掉以获得更好的镜头，但他们希望我们的摄像操作员去应对真实空间的局限性。但他们确实做的是，他们把所有的窗户都做成了可以向上或向下倾斜。
slant down. Yeah, they had a little tilty thing on the side. And that was a trick so that you couldn't see the reflection of the camera operators in the glass. Otherwise, you would have seen them all the time. That's right. It's like when you take a selfie with sunglasses on. Yeah. It is just like that, Ang. Let me relate it back to selfies. Well, the guys are going to get back to their little mini basketball game. They don't listen to Pam. And D'Angelo's going to invite Jim to join. But you know, D'Angelo's been a real big talker all along. He's a big talker about all of his basketball stuff. And he's really showboating about how he can dunk. Mm-hmm. And Jim's like, well, why don't we see you dunk on a real hoop? We have one in the warehouse. Yeah. Jim's tired
是的，侧面有一个小倾斜装置。这是一个小把手，这样你就不会在玻璃里看到摄像操作员的倒影了。否则你总是会看到他们。没错。就像你戴着太阳镜自拍一样。是的，就是那样，安吉。让我把它跟自拍联系起来。好吧，小伙子们要回去玩他们的小型篮球赛了。他们不听帕姆的话。而德安吉洛邀请吉姆加入。但你知道的，德安吉洛从头到尾都是个很能说的人。他很会吹嘘自己所有的篮球技能，而且他一直在炫耀自己有多会扣篮。嗯哼。吉姆就说，那我们为什么不去看看你在真正的篮筐上扣篮呢？我们在仓库里有一个。是的。吉姆受够了他的牛皮。他要当面戳穿他。
of his BS. And he's going to call him out. Yeah. D'Angelo says, yeah, we'll set that up sometime. And Jim's like, how about today? How about right now? Yeah. And D'Angelo's like, I don't know. And we think he's going to try to get out of it. And then he says, well, no one has called NASA to request a lift off. That's right. Game on. Game on. They're going to go down to the warehouse. Jim has measured out the distance from the baseline to the free throw line. But he makes a mistake. Did you catch it? No. So Jim says, the free throw line is 15 feet from the baseline. It's not. It's 15 feet from the basket. From the goal. Yeah. It's 19 feet from the baseline. Oh, yeah. I'm just saying. Yeah. I thought you'd be impressed. I am very impressed.
是的。德安吉洛说，行吧，我们改天安排一下。吉姆就说，今天怎么样？现在怎么样？是的。而德安吉洛就像是，我不知道。我们以为他要想法子推脱。然后他说，好吧，没人打电话给美国宇航局要求发射升空。没错。比赛开始。比赛开始。他们要下到仓库去。吉姆量好了从底线到罚球线的距离。但他犯了个错误。你注意到了吗？没有。所以吉姆说，罚球线距离底线15英尺。其实不是。距离篮筐是15英尺。从球门算。是的。距离底线是19英尺。哦，对。我只是随便说说。是的。我以为你会印象深刻。我印象非常深刻。
Basketball. I didn't know that. Okay. Let me confess, I read that on Dunderpedia. Oh, thank you, Dunderpedia. You're welcome. Thank you, Dunderpedia. I would not have caught that on my own. We should also say Dwight attends because D'Angelo yells at him. Yes. So loudly and Dwight responds to strong leadership. When Will Ferrell as D'Angelo yelled like that, it was so hard not to laugh. He's funny at yelling. He's funny at everything. I got a little nugget for you guys. Something that wasn't scripted. When D'Angelo says, does someone want to sit in Kevin's lap? That was scripted. Okay. But when he says, Angela, and I say no, and he says Oscar, and Oscar says, no, thank you. Yeah. That was not in the script. I love that moment so much.
篮球。我不知道这个。好吧。我坦白，我是从邓德百科上看到的。哦，谢谢你，邓德百科。不客气。谢谢你，邓德百科。靠我自己我可发现不了这个。我们还应该说德怀特也参加了，因为德安吉洛对他大吼大叫。是的。声音那么大，而且德怀特吃强硬领导这一套。当威尔·法瑞尔饰演的德安吉洛那样大吼大叫时，太难忍住不笑了。他吼人的样子真搞笑。他干什么都搞笑。我给你们带了个小彩蛋。一段没有写在剧本里的内容。当德安吉洛说，有人想坐在凯尔的腿上吗？那是剧本里有的。好吧。但当他说，安吉拉，我说不，然后他说奥斯卡，而奥斯卡说，不，谢谢。是的。那不在剧本里。我太喜欢那个时刻了。
That is so great. Well, guys, what's going to happen is that D'Angelo is going to dunk the ball and then the whole, what do you call that thing? Basketball hoop thing falls on him and he's going to get sent to the hospital. The whole thing teeters over on top of him, which would be very, very bad because those things are really heavy. Fan question from Magsy in Yorkville, Illinois. How did you guys do the scene when D'Angelo does the basketball dunk? Well, everyone, this was our stunt gone horribly wrong. Yeah. When Greg was in the studio with us, we asked him if he remembered this moment. He did. Here's what he had to say. I still think about that constantly. It was horrible. And I wasn't running the show then.
太棒了。好吧，各位，接下来发生的是德安吉洛扣了篮，然后整个——你们管那个叫什么？篮球架直接砸在他身上，他被送去了医院。整个东西直接朝他砸塌下来，这可真是糟透了，因为那玩意儿真的很重。来自伊利诺伊州约克维尔的玛格茜的粉丝提问：当德安吉洛完成篮球扣篮时，你们是怎么拍那一幕的？好吧，各位，这是我们的特技效果出了重大差错。是的。当格雷格在录音室和我们在一起时，我们问他是否还记得这个时刻。他记得。他是这么说的。我至今还在不断想起那件事。太可怕了。当时我并没有负责这个节目。
Paul was. And I was coming in to watch and there was Will Ferrell. And the joke was that he was going to dunk this basketball in the warehouse. And our special effects guys had rigged a harness for him and a rope and a pulley. And their idea was he's going to run, he's going to jump as high as he can jump. And then at the very apex of his jump, they were going to yank on this clothesline and he was going to seamlessly continue his arc until he was tall enough to dunk and that it would look like he could dunk the ball. And I had enormous reservations about this, just from the physics of it. I was like, I can't understand. Skeptical. Yeah. The idea that his mass is going to,
是保罗负责。我当时去现场观看，威尔·法瑞尔也在。那个笑话是他要在仓库里扣这个篮球。我们的特效人员为他设计了一套威亚衣、一根绳子和一个滑轮。他们的想法是他跑过去，尽可能高地跳起来。然后在他人生的最高点，他们会猛地拉动这条安全绳，他就会顺畅地继续他的弧线，直到他足够高可以扣篮，这样看起来就像他真的能扣篮一样。我对此有着极大的保留意见，纯粹是从物理学角度来看。我就觉得，我无法理解。持怀疑态度。是的。他的质量在开始下落前的一瞬间，他们要顺畅地让它继续。而且你还不能看出来。所以我非常怀疑。就像第一次拍摄时，他跳起来，然后他，你知道的，开始下落，他们开始拉这个东西，你知道的，看起来就像那种不可能实现的诡异上下运动。
just as, just before it starts to go down, they're going to seamlessly keep it going. And you're not going to be able to tell. So I was very skeptical. And like the first take, he jumps and then he, you know, starts to fall and they start pulling on this thing, you know, and it just looks like this weird up and down thing that is not possible. And, and then they're like, no, no, you got to pull harder. You didn't pull hard enough. The second, you know, the next take he runs, they yank on this thing and he's just pile driven into the rim of the basketball with horrible crash. And we're like, Oh my God, you know, he was so nice to come help us out, do a few episodes. And it was just, it was such a disaster.
然后他们说，不，不，你们得拉得更用力点。你们拉得不够用力。第二次，你知道的，接下来的拍摄他跑起来，他们猛拉这个东西，他直接被重重地砸向了篮球框，发出一声可怕的巨响。我们当时就想，哦天哪，你知道的，他那么好心来帮我们拍几集。这简直成了一场灾难。我记得很清楚。我永远不会忘记。太令人震惊了。太疯狂了，安吉拉。我的大脑简直无法理解。就像我不明白他是怎么从地面一下子飞到那么高的。我只记得当时惊呆了。好吧，兰迪说特技助理拉得太猛了，导致他飞得比他们计划的要高得多。他的膝盖狠狠撞在了篮球框上，他的腿上被划开了一个很深的口子，就在膝盖下方一点。
I remember it. I will never forget it. It was so shocking. It was crazy, Angela. Like my brain couldn't wrap itself around it. Like I didn't understand how he got from the ground up there so fast. And I remember just being stunned. Well, Randy said that the stunt assistants pulled so hard that he flew up much higher than they planned. His knee got rammed into the basketball hoop and he got a really bad cut on his leg, like just below his knee. We had to bring our set medic out and all that stuff. Randy said he was going to call a wrap on it and just be like, forget it. We're not doing this again. And he said, we'll pull them aside. And he said, Hey, listen, I don't want you to blame anyone. I don't want you to punish anyone.
我们不得不叫来现场医疗队之类的。兰迪说他当时打算直接收工不拍了，就当算了吧。我们不拍了。他说，我们会把他拉到一边，然后他说，嘿，听着，我不想让你怪任何人。我不想让你惩罚任何人。我很好。我一点都不疼。我想再试一次。我是说，什么？是的，威尔·法瑞尔。我知道。我要是遇到这事，绝对会说，我要回家了。但我发现我总是看到人们在那种情况下硬撑过去，而我会说，我撤了。再见。兰迪说，应威尔的要求，他允许再拍一次。而且那一次他们自动修正了。是的，他们有点托着他，但最终呈现出来的效果其实并不是他们所需要的。但到了那个时候，他们觉得，我们收工吧。我们只能用现有的素材了。兰迪说在收工时，他把威尔·法瑞尔送到了车上，他一直在不停地道歉，并问，你要去急诊室吗？我们能为你的腿伤做点什么？
I am fine. I am not in pain. I'd like to try it again. I mean, what? Yeah, Will Ferrell. I know. I would be like, I am going home. But I think that like all the time I watch people like tough it out in situations and I'm like, I'm out. Goodbye. Randy said he allowed one more take at Will's request. And that that time they auto corrected. Yeah, they kind of lifted him and it never really ended up being what they needed. But at that point, they were like, we're calling it. We're just going to have to go with the footage that we have. Randy said that at rap, he walked Will Ferrell to his car and he was just like apologizing profusely and saying like, do you want to go to the ER? Like, what can we do for this cut on your leg? And he said that Will looked at him and quoted
他说威尔看着他，引用了巨蟒剧团的一句名言，对他说：只是擦伤而已，不过是皮外肉伤。噢。并且向他保证，他说，我会没事的。明天早上我会按时上班的。不用担心。哇。我知道。好吧，我对这一幕的拍摄剧本里写了什么很好奇。剧本上是这样写的。一辆救护车驶出停车场，警灯闪烁，警笛长鸣。所有人都惊呆了。达里尔很担心，问，他会没事吧？安迪说，急救人员说大概不会。哦天哪。这本会把我们带到结尾的彩蛋戏。德安吉洛本会穿着病号服出现，头上缠着绷带。他说着胡话。吉姆会要求艾伦打911。我最喜欢的时刻之一就是艾伦说……
a famous line from Monty Python and just said to his butt a scratch merely a flesh wound. Aw. And he assured him, he said, I'll be fine. I'll be on time for work tomorrow morning. Don't you worry. Wow. I know. Well, I was curious about what was in the shooting draft for this moment. And this is what it says. And ambulance pulls out of the parking lot, lights flashing, sirens blaring. Everyone is stunned. Daryl is worried and says, will he be okay? And Andy says, the EMT said probably not. Oh my gosh. This would have taken us to a tag scene at the end. D'Angelo was going to show up in a hospital gown with his head bandage. He's speaking gibberish. Jim is going to ask Aaron to call 911. One of my favorite moments is when Aaron says,
我该说是谁打来的？我知道。吉姆说，艾伦。我有两个问题。第一，帕姆在这个彩蛋里去哪了？我不知道。你知道的，原本德安吉洛坐在帕姆的电脑前开始打字。所以我不能在那儿。这就是我不在那儿的原因之一，因为他要来打字。而且你知道的，我不知道你在拍摄剧本里有没有看到这个，这集的结尾，镜头本会摇过来，我们会看到电脑屏幕，我们会看到德安吉洛打的字。是的。尽管他说着胡话，但他打出的内容是——珍娜，你有写下来吧？我有。这就是本该作为最后一个镜头的画面。请帮帮我。我神志清醒，我成了自己身体的囚犯。
who should I say is calling? I know. And Jim goes, Aaron. And there are two things I have a question about. One, where is Pam in this tag? I don't know. You know, originally D'Angelo sits down at Pam's computer and starts typing. So I couldn't be there. That's why one reason why I'm not there is because he was going to come type. And you know, I don't know if you saw this in the shooting draft, but the very end of this episode, the camera was going to swing over and we were going to computer screen and we were going to see what D'Angelo had typed. Yes. And even though he was speaking gibberish, he would have typed, Jenna, you have it, right? I have it. This is what would have been the last shot. Please help. I am of sound mind and I am a prisoner in my body.
我的家人正在安排取得对我的法定监护权，并打算下达生前预嘱（DNR）。这不符合我的利益。请联系我的律师弗雷德·内斯特。他的电话在我梳妆台上的黑莓手机里，就在我手表左边。是的。是的。本该这样结束的。结果，结局是他们把踉踉跄跄的他护送了出去。各位，这一幕我实在没法憋住。你们完全能看到我在笑。你们看到我在微笑和大笑，因为，你知道的，他们给威尔写了几句胡话，但后来他基本上开始即兴乱编了。是的。而且每次都不太一样，我根本憋不住。这集的最后我完全不够专业。我会把它发到动态里，但我彻底笑场了。好吧，多亏了明尼苏达州的尼克·N，我给你们找了个时间码。
My family is arranging to have power of attorney over me and intends to issue a DNR order. This is not in my interest. Please contact my lawyer, Fred Nestor. His number is in my blackberry, which is on my dresser to the left of my watch. Yeah. Yeah. That's how it would have ended. Instead, it ends with them sort of escorting him out. You guys, I couldn't keep it together in this scene. You fully see me laugh. You see me smile and laugh because, you know, they wrote out a few gibberish words for Will, but then he mostly just started to make stuff up. Yes. And it was a little different each time and I couldn't keep it together. I'm fully unprofessional at the end of this episode. I'll put it in stories, but I totally break. Well, I've got a timecode for you
有人也看到了吗？是的。是21分25秒。然后几乎紧接着，尼克指出在21分35秒，就在威尔发出打喷嚏的声音之后，你可以看到约翰把头往地板方向低下去，试图掩饰他的笑意，但他的肢体语言出卖了他，镜头一切换的瞬间他就笑得前俯后仰了。好吧，在跟这一集说再见之前，珍娜，我想给你读一篇我在《纽约时报》上看到的文章，作者是戴夫·伊茨科夫。发表于2011年4月6日。他曾来到片场采访威尔·法瑞尔，聊聊出演《办公室》的感受，以及这对于迈克尔·斯科特离开后的节目意味着什么。你和我在这期间都经历过，当时有很多不确定性。好吧，这是……
thanks to Nick N in Minnesota. Did someone else see that? Yeah. It's 21 minutes and 25 seconds. And then almost right after that, Nick pointed out at 2135, right after Will makes a sneezing noise, you can see John tilt his head down to the floor to try and hide his smile, but his body language says that he broke into hysterical laughter the very moment the scene cuts. Well, before we say goodbye to this episode, Jenna, I wanted to read you an article I found in The New York Times by Dave Itzkoff. It came out April 6th of 2011. He had come to set to interview Will Ferrell about being on the office and about what this meant for the show with Michael Scott leaving. You and I have shared during this time there was a lot of uncertainty. Well, here's
他说的话。对于《办公室》的制片人们来说，他们在对节目未来的愿景上可能缺乏明确性或坦诚，但他们在紧张感上绝对是有过之而无不及。当被问及卡瑞尔先生的潜在替代者时，利伯斯坦先生变得有些激动。他在说出最终的答案之前，多次开始、停止并收回他的回答。我们决定在史蒂夫之后继续使用我们现有的演员阵容，因为我们拥有这套阵容。即便如此，《办公室》还是在5月19日的季终集里大量启用了像里奇·热维斯和威尔·阿奈特这样的客串明星，同时拉高了观众对迈克尔·斯科特全职替代者官宣的期待。好吧，我得告诉你，女士，为了迎接这一季的收官以及迈入下一季，我一直在尽可能地深挖，
what he said. What the office producers may lack in clarity or candor about their vision for the show's future they amply make up for in nervousness. Asked a few questions about a possible replacement for Mr. Carell, Mr. Lieberstein became agitated. He started, stopped, and retracted his responses multiple times before settling on the following answer. We have decided to go past Steve with the cast we have because of the cast we have. Even so, the office is front-loading its May 19th finale with guest stars like Ricky Gervais and Will Arnett while ratcheting up anticipation for an announcement of Michael Scott's full-time replacement. Well, I'll tell you this lady in anticipation of finishing out this season and moving into next season, I have been digging as
试图找到幕后八卦的信息。我发现了一些挺有意思的事情，我很兴奋能分享出来，但我要等到我们开启第八季的时候再说。哦天哪，珍娜，我太喜欢你脑子里冒出新点子的时候了。我想我记得很多事情，但我认为也有我不了解的事情，而且我很想知道。哦，好吧，我等不及了。我会拭目以待的。我要说的是，我确实被拉进了保罗的办公室单独谈话，他征求了我对下一任经理人选的意见。真的吗？哦，你得把这些都爆出来。我会分享的。好吧。我会留到第八季分享。好了，这就是《核心圈子》，猜猜怎么着？下周我们将迎来威尔·法瑞尔的回归。他会加入我们，
much as I can to try to find information on the behind-the-scenes scuttlebutt. And I've found out some kind of fun things and I'm excited to share but I'm gonna wait until we kick off season eight. Oh my gosh, Jenna, I love it when you get a B in your bonnet. I'm like, I remember a lot of things but then I think there's things I don't know and I want to know. Oh well, I can't wait. I will be looking forward to that. I will say this, I did get pulled into Paul's office for a one-on-one where he asked my opinion of who I thought should be the next manager. Really? Oh, you've got to give all that up. I'll share. Okay. I'll share for season eight. Well, that was Inner Circle and guess what? Next week we're going to be back with Will Ferrell. He's going to join us and he's going
并且谈谈他在剧中的故事线。祝大家有个美好的一周。我们爱你们。回头见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·巴芭·科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用优惠码：Office。这一集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
to talk about his arc on the show. You guys have a great week. We love you. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubba Co. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来聊聊他在剧中的心路历程。大家过个愉快的一周。我们爱你们。到时见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制作人是艾因斯利·巴巴·科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。有关《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。要获得 Stitcher Premium 的一个月免费试用，请使用代码 Office。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。